[Music]
in sad times news I should use this one
for the so vibrato submitted by Triple D
Dallas TX or should I just say text sis
okay there it is three people have died
and many more injured after a player
opened fire during a Madden video game
tournament oh my god that's sad Florida
let me try to line this up that's a that
bagent Joe I like every funeral just
like have you guys ever been to a Korean
person funeral no oh yeah dude did you
see the [ __ ] screaming fest no I pre
mean that like there's a party like oh
there's a couple of Wailers
yeah like Korean funerals like whaling
is the part of the culture and like I
didn't know that does that sound like
what's whaling like like that like [ __ ]
at a funeral at a funeral because you're
you're like lamenting hard as you're
getting it all out so like when my
grandma passed away that's not fun yeah
my grandma passed away like remind you
I'm bawling my eyes out I was like super
close to my grandma but then my mom
didn't give me a heads up about the the
whaling part so as I'm crying my mom
disgust look at oh she snapped me out of
my crying because it threw me off I was
like what the [ __ ] is this is there like
a designated time no you any time so
usually typically what'll happen is the
person who passed away you'll have the
the family that's not front with their
picture behind you in whatever they earn
or whatever the casket behind you people
say they're that they're sorry for you
and they're just screaming what if
they're all in tune and had a vibrato
that big time would you be like oh mom
damn what the [ __ ] that's time come on
so you're a little off you little flat
real quick
yeah you're dancing no do you think that
do you think this story like if they're
very aware of the story they like are
they gonna talk about our story maybe no
so where's this plan thing it's at a
public visit Florida right so this takes
place in Jacksonville Florida like in an
arena all the government know this took
place at a it's called Chicago pizza and
Sports Grill is a restaurant like a
sports bar well I thought it was like a
big convention yeah I thought I was like
I actually eat games like competition
it's like going around table and play
some arcade games just know they had
this room in the back of the restaurant
where they had like about I think
they're saying like 60 people that were
just like some of our players other
people were spectators did you say
Chicago oh yeah so I'm gonna play a
video clip that will tell you
information and you can also hear some
of the shots oh my god oh no warning
these ones make me so sad but then Joe
got the West also pretty line it up I'll
lighten it up guys ready Cantara guys
I'll save the tears from coming out oh
are you serious during a Madden NFL 19
video hundreds of people from around the
country came to play oh my god only
connotations you can hear the shots
being fired and then screams why why
before taking his own life police say
David Katz killed two gamers 28 year old
Taylor Robertson oh honey two-year-old
Israel to Sonya in this image a red dot
can be seen on Elijah's chest Oh what
was the thought the bullet no the laser
so it was it was premeditated hehe
didn't freak out it was premeditated
witnesses are saying that earlier he
lost the tournament tournament which
happened when you play games yeah but he
won the 2017 one so like in his mind he
was like the best player like obviously
he didn't like losing so he went back
and he pulled out his handgun he went
back to the event started shooting
people so he pulled it out from his car
whatever from his room well he went all
the way home he's from Baltimore how do
you know where he lives being at a hotel
idaho telling you right and so he shot
himself after he killed himself yes you
know what I think about is like did he
bring that gun the year before yeah and
he would have lost the probable he
killed them too cuz from Baltimore to
Florida I don't know if he went on a
road trip or like he probably came in
knowing that that is crazy
never news there were nine additional
victims that were shot and injured and
two victims I had other injuries like
while they were trying to flee so a lot
of people were hurt including him that
sucks he got to kill himself he was 24
years old right they are reporting that
when he was a teenager there were two
times where he went to a mental
institution so he had like mental issues
but a lot of people are asking how was
he even able to get in gorgeous these
guns legally by the way how was he able
to purchase these two guns legally and
that's because in his state you have to
have 30 consecutive days in a mental
hospital in order for you to be banned
from getting a gun but his to state hmm
like one was 12 days ago almost 13 days
so it wasn't enough to like stop him
from getting to him that's crazy
his dad works for NASA his mom has a PhD
works for FDA too busy to love your
child huh they had a really ugly divorce
he has an older brother and they're
saying like they both of the kids had
issues mental issues well if he did damn
that sucks and man astronauts can have
[ __ ] up kids too man
whoa okay as soon as you said NASA I saw
like Buzz Aldrin and [ __ ] like with two
kids no there's like a ton of other jobs
in it I know but that's the best you
think it was like SpaceX was killing the
game and then NASA was like [ __ ] and
then he had to take that so then he
started falling off and then he started
taking it out on his kid and his kids
starting decisions no they got divorced
before SpaceX well you could take this
out of the video yeah I mean we like to
make our own food in the NASCAR so the
whole time I thought he was a racecar
driver okay you did what Joe did there
are other jobs you know what's crazy is
um this isn't really that new I mean not
to play this down but then I remember
when I was in high school we used to go
these like PC banks were like we would
play counter-strike in like like Red
Alert or whatever we would there's
there's these computer cafes and then
people will get into a fight over video
games and [ __ ] or like like losing and
then they would do its kind of shoot
each other that's a regular actually
yeah just like a complete for god but
that was like a regular thing especially
like in the asian community where our
Asian gang community it was I mean they
were just dancers loved video games
France too like so drugs that they were
maybe laundering money I don't know what
it was but then like some people will
catch win like there's a there's a gang
hanging out there playing video games so
then they'll come in and start shooting
up shooting up the place and stuff
there's one next to a garden gap cafe
next to Garfield that got shot up all
the time I forgot it was called people
just kept coming back anyway just keep
coming back you're addicted to [ __ ]
video games that's [ __ ] good and
people like hella people would get shot
in there so better because it's all
Asian it just doesn't really make the
news you know yeah
and I remember illusion lives matter -
they do
you'll be like still be like nerdy ass
kids in there just trying to play games
and then don't like alongside that
you'll see like a cholo like playing
Buse next to them it's like the most
bizarre [ __ ] ever yeah oh those like
that pools yeah I mean but Paul you
can't expect Margherita beer
but like at a computer cafe not really
right I mean one of my buddies has a
bullet lodged in his skull from
altercation that he had at one of those
places is he capable yeah I mean like it
just well what happened is it was a 22
so 22 is like a really small bullet
really most common one yeah yeah yeah
but you know he got into like a argument
with another guy and then you know I
guess it's over you know game [ __ ] and
then he just he just basically pulled
out a gun and started chasing him and
shooting him and then so when they all
got in the car and they were driving off
the guy was shooting like at the car and
it hit like a side metal part and then
it went through the backseat like the
headrest
and they went inside of his skull and it
stayed there and so the doctor was like
if you remove that then the crack would
open up so you just they just left it
there oh he got lucky did ya do the
[ __ ] gamers are so intense my brother
that that fool used to love games he
doesn't play games anymore but I
remember we played this game called
Tekken ooh Eddie Goro so I sucked at
games but then somehow I beat him once
and he was so [ __ ] mad and because I
knew he was many wanted rematch I never
gave him the P match oh I may have even
more pissed oh yeah people will tear
their [ __ ] up - it wasn't it I remember
I choked my friend because we're paying
[Laughter]
I beat you at games and you get upset I
always beat you at video games we played
twice and you lost you got upset no we
played more than that and I beat you
every day in the game watch watch watch
watch backs watching the game me tennis
oh damn you bowling do you have to think
probably Mario Kart ooh
Mario Kart separates relationships
sometimes dang did you know I was the
one that lost my temper that's right so
you remember and you [ __ ] smash the
class against the wall you go say
damn you started people you get the
middle the floor out of nowhere out of
know what does that look like when you
get mad
uke oh I wish I had my phone I broke the
[ __ ] out of it it's right here oh [ __ ]
oh no no the one before this oh I need
like a case within a case breaking your
phone is so satisfying is it
no this well the thing is like I get
upset where was my temper for like the
reasons of like like or someone can't
produce what I but or what they believe
they could do yeah in this certain
scenario that I'm talking about
what are you believe in yourself the way
I do okay we but we got our dogs I inter
pares guard dogs
off the list of Craig and then that
night we found out like dad ticks oh so
it's like 2:00 a.m. and we're pulling
out ticks and then she's trying to find
like a that that's 24-hour which is
already kind of difficult and then I'm
trying to FaceTime my aunt because she's
done this tick thing before it's the ex
the iPhone X trash and then it's just
like the FaceTime is pausing and I'm
justifying why I lost my temper but it's
because we couldn't help the dogs and I
was like I got [ __ ] pissed this
shouldn't call me dog ya know cuz I used
to have ticks in my bushes Oh bushes and
my dogs always have [ __ ] little
grapes in their necks and [ __ ] you know
the little tick gets [ __ ] in yeah
yeah half yeah there's a way you got to
pull out there there little [ __ ]
longers could it's like a hook it stays
in there so you gotta like get tweezers
and lift it up and it as it lifts up
like this then you stick a little needle
and you [ __ ] wiggle that [ __ ] and you
pop it off oh yeah we just pulled it out
why you do so much because the their
mouth stays inside yeah okay
I mean the doors of calvinism your
condition affecting but that's okay I
mean we got okay and usually you know
you could just get some medicine and it
comes out earlier because it was like 2
a.m. we did not know what to do with
taste 24/7 of that place in k-town
everybody goes yeah Pasadena in Pasadena
alone we went to one but I feel like
they were sketchy that I get your dog
probably needs this that and this we're
gonna they check the dog in front of you
but then they're like well we're gonna
go check
back it's like well he just did
everything else in front of us what you
do it in the back there's nothing wrong
with your kit then - it's a dog bro all
right whatever shady mechanic
yup you're gonna need an oil change Mac
these like cat dog or whatever it is but
something's wrong ya'll need something
[Music]
[Music]